hey guys how's it going Justine here
today we are going to do an unboxing of
the new Apple TV there's two different
versions I got the 64 gig which is not
actually a lot of space but that was the
highest capacity one that they currently
have we're gonna do an unboxing and
we're gonna check this little guy out
I've got my neck completely unnecessary
this remote I hope they have remotes
already sold separately album with the
old Apple TVs is admirable the remote
and I'd be screwed and I wouldn't be
able to change the Wi-Fi network without
the remote this feels good very tactile
here's the TV itself it looks to be
about double the size of the previous
one this way feels quite substantial
like a nice a small brick perhaps listen
can I take this off nice matte black
that's your HDMI your Ethernet port a
little micro look what are you most we
have in here your power adapter of these
directions this light table so you won't
be war no you are not
oh it's a USBC kind of say this doesn't
look like a micro USB you need to like
be able to charge the remote so so silly
lightning cables used to charge the
remote silly silly goose I'm excited to
try to play some games on the Apple TV I
think that's going to be the real
game-changer literal game changer
because a lot of people love playing iOS
games and that's basically all they ever
play so now that you're going to give up
latest iOS games on your television it's
gonna be kind of cool one thing I did
notice is they do not give you an HDMI
cable so this is the Apple TV I hope you
guys enjoyed this unboxing it was kind
of basic because they really
much of it comes with this check back
later because I will do an Apple TV
setup and a test of some of the features
especially gaming because that's gonna
be really clear to try out so only know
what games you guys are playing let me
know if you've got the Apple TV and what
you guys think and if you don't have an
Apple TV what do you use to watch TV on
your TV bye let's go set you up no not
good are you trying to help me or are
you just making things more difficult
for me here entertain yourself with that